we gotta give some love to one of the
greatest sponsors ever
adamandeve.com uh your one-stop shop for
everything
sexy um adam and eve is the number one
trusted
source for adult toys in business for
almost 50 years now they have 24
7 customer support 90 day no hassle
returns and discrete packaging
20 of their profit goes to help fight
the spread of hiv around the world which
is awesome oh wow
speaking of sex toys you know what i
realized
the only time a woman ever finds out her
vibrator doesn't work anymore and it's
breaking down is when she's in the mood
i'm not saying that it happened to me
recently i think you're kind of saying
that
and i'm not saying that i used our code
to get a new toy because i was pissed i
think you did use our code
but if i were to have used the code it
would be at adamandeve.com
and the code is mood m-o-o-d for 50
off one item plus free shipping in the
u.s and canada
so maybe i did get 50 off maybe maybe
you were in the mood maybe
yeah maybe i kind of feel like you were
yeah
maybe allegedly again visit
adamandeve.com and use the code mood
for 50 off one item plus free shipping
in the us
and canada
you know what today's topic is by the
way is what to splurge and save on i
feel like that's worth a splurge
for your splooge yeah
hello welcome back to big mood everybody
i'm nikki
that was good that was good i got to
give you that one that was
oh thank you i like that i had some
coffee
splurge on your coffee some splurge for
your sploosh yes
this is uh this is tiff right next to me
yep i'm tiff
and this is gina all alone for all you
new people welcome happy new year
jess is not here yeah is this in
february i'm like happy new year
everyone's like we're over it happy
chinese new year don't be
ignorant okay what's the year of the
year of the oh [ __ ] what is it i just
looked it up dude i forgot about
this yeah go ahead i kind of want to see
what it is
i think it's uh i'm gonna guess like a
goat
is it a goat i hope i'm right it is
uh what's the animal ox
oh that's an ox
does that mean next year is a tiger is
that is it you know the order
well only because steve's an ox and i'm
a tiger and i'm when you're younger
that makes sense dragons are right
before the snakes they talk about it too
that's me too
because casey's a dragon i'm a snake
it's very important information
everybody
and now that we've covered the very
important topic let's get some
[Laughter]
so now that we're in our 30s all of us
are deep in our 30s
deep in our heads hey early
we're all in our early 30s okay but now
that you're in here
um looking back on your 20s she's mad
we do a lot of like videos of finance
and
mentioning investments and stuff but we
don't uh
talk about how important it is to have
the capital saved up to do that
and you should be doing that as young as
possible so looking back on your 20s
what were some like stupid things that
you spent money on
that you wish you would have saved on
and looking back what do you wish you
would have
actually spent money on right damn
i think for me i wish i would have spent
more money or
like because i didn't really splurge on
anything oh i'm quality
okay i did have a kid too you didn't
have a kid you splurged on a kid yeah i
splurged on a child because i did have
them at 18.
so poor poor money management by the way
i'm just saying
oh the child kid thing yeah money
management yeah it wasn't a good
financial
decision food shelter for diapers and
stuff you need to treat yourself
decreases in value
by far actually no he's skating about
it's like
it's like a like a 30-year investment
until they actually start making money
and take care of you
it's true and then they do they go back
and actually take care of you no
well my 13 year old is doing a pretty
good job well that's good i love him put
that little guy
with love he's taking care of me with
love he pays you in love
yeah he does sweet cheap little bastard
it's worth more than gold decay this is
true this is true
you can't even buy it i don't even buy
it why can't you just believe it
except that i believe in science no fail
don't appropriate my culture
i like that i got to do it i was talking
to youtube girl
no no i am latina on um
a cat food bag you know what i learned
recently so there's
okay so we've heard of um hey check it
out the higher the socks that down or
the fool right
why did you hear that oh you guys ever
heard that no okay so
when i stream for some reason we always
go to that that easily accent for no
goddamn reason
cause there's this guy that came to my
yeah there's this guy that comes into my
stream and his name is foo
so whenever we see him we're like oh
check it out
you know what they say the higher the
socks the downer the fool
but we also learned a new one the
the bigger the hoop earrings that's what
i was gonna say the bigger the hoop the
bigger the hoe
no no the bigger the hoop earrings the
bigger the cholo's feelings
well i'm glad they changed it that's
very progressive wearing my hoops today
for this joke right here i can see your
butt i see your butt
oh hey was it nice yeah it was okay
i feel like um looking back i would have
want
i wish i'd put together an emergency
fund because
so many people don't have an emergency
fund and i think that when you don't
have that and there's gonna be an
emergency
you're gonna have an emergency that's
when you get into trouble with credit
card debt or at least for me that's what
it was
like i went through a breakup and then i
had to pay the full rent instead of like
half the rent like i was paying
now and i just didn't i just didn't
consider that that could ever happen
and if i think if i had an emergency
fund that would have been a good thing
to definitely
put together you could totally just put
like five dollars away a week
yeah it piles up it adds up i think
uh one thing i regret was compile
yeah true it works the one thing i
regret is i didn't need that nice
apartment
it was stupid did you have a really nice
apartment it was a cute like studio i
was paying 1500 a month
like there's like no where in cape town
oh
yeah like i didn't need to do you have a
doorman
uh no not worth it in k town then yeah
right
i don't know what the hell you need some
security oh wait we did have a doorman
sorry door security but not like the one
at the front desk oh
not like no one with a hat yeah yeah
like new york ones
uh and it was just like i it's because i
was like i want to move out on my
own live in the city you know like i'm a
big girl so i got an apartment
and like you know i furnished it and
stuff and i was like oh my god this is
so expensive what am i blowing my money
on and this this was also stupidly
during the time where i was traveling a
lot
yeah you were never there i was never
there wow
yeah it was so dumb i went from like
uh living at home with my family for
like four hundred dollars a month
to fifteen hundred dollars and i'm just
like this is the dumbest decision ever
and now like i'm back with roommates
like i make even more money now than i
did then but i'm sticking with really
you learned
yeah i learned and then so i'm like i'm
just gonna [ __ ] do this because like
we gotta we
the amount that we pay we get like a
whole house yeah awesome
um geo used to bone in that room so i
get to smell it all right
so it was like i think you're doing it
right yeah
if i was single um and not like in a
super serious relationship
i would 100 save my money and have
roommates right
it's really smart and like yeah yeah
i'll pile up that money yeah pile it up
support investments and stuff
and then i see i have a few friends now
who are like around
like that age where i got my apartment
like 24 25
they're like oh yeah we actually want to
get like this really nice high-rise
apartment
like in downtown and i was just like no
don't do it yeah cause they're gonna be
paying like
1900 bucks a month each i think when
you're in your 20s
sometimes you can get caught up in the
image of it all
yeah yeah and like the idealized version
of like what you want to be
as an adult right and you haven't like
done the baby steps to get there
exactly and then you just get in hot
water and
and you know what happens to everybody
that whole like downtown living it's
such a
20s dream and i never lived out my 20s
dream of having a downtown like
high-rise
apartment but i wish i did oh like yeah
i mean i don't
regret not having it but if i could have
i wish i would have done it you know
what i mean
but because it's one of those like life
experiences that you're like oh cool i
got that out of my system now i can move
on
right yeah i didn't get that right
i still kind of feel that pull now
because then now i'm just like oh i can
really afford like this you know like
i can get a nice one and i can do like i
have sex in the city look at my view
yeah and all that but okay wait can i
pitch you
huh because you're in your 30s now and i
feel like you kind of can for your
um for yourself but i'd rather buy a
house if
what if you didn't buy a hole or like
rent a whole like huge
high-rise but just like a little studio
but it's really nice
yeah but a little studio and it's a
business expense because you're taking
all your pictures there
and you like that's like your social
media
studio to like more it takes more yeah
thank you i just i don't know it's like
i cause right now nothing beats what i'm
what i'm living it's true you know like
nothing but the deal you got is
pretty great yeah it's like you're
practically living at home with your
parents exactly like that's
how financially smart that is yeah so
and like now i'm just like telling my
friends like don't do it man don't do it
yeah i do feel more in them
but now i'm more towards like i'd rather
just buy a house or a condo on my own
yeah definitely i think that if i think
you're
that's so doable for you that like it
would be dumb for you to blow it right
now on a
on a studio but if you were to make sure
it's a business expense
um i feel like i read so many like
financial books before i hit my 20s that
i did make sure that all of my big
spends were
business expenses which was great i
think that good job 20s
nikki but i did take um a poll on
instagram
but you can follow me at nikkilima or
you can follow our page
at big mood girls or any other
individual pages but i originally did it
because i wasn't sure if i was gonna do
a [ __ ] they don't tell you episode on it
and i was just curious because
um i wanted to know if my feelings were
reflected and they kind of were
so the top things that i think i would
go back and spend money on that aren't
business expenses
are exercise and grooming like
you don't have to spend a lot of money
but put time into like
your health to like your physical taking
care of that your titties
that was a great business expense there
you go never regret these babies
ever as a model that's an investment i
could see that
i could see that um but yeah like
because your muscles atrophy over time
no matter what like even if you're
working out or not working out
you're gonna have muscle loss so what
you're doing by
investing in um exercise or workout
classes or whatever
is you're preserving that muscle loss
skin care stuff too yeah skincare
sunscreen
ever since i was like early 20s i always
heard like you shower sunscreen every
single day and i'm like okay
i'll do it and um thirty-one
i really just started i really thought
until i was 28
28 is when i started i really thought if
you had a darker complexion you didn't
really need sunscreen
i really thought that i started at 24
and i still regret not starting sooner
so for those of you out there sunscreen
every day there's specific sunscreens
there's always excuses like oh it looks
like this white stuff in my face no
there's sunscreens that don't do that
they're specifically for your face if
you have darker skin you still need to
use it even if it's not sunny outside
you still need to use it
i put sunscreen on at home and a lot of
asian people do because
the light that comes through the windows
the blue light that comes through your
computer and stuff is still bad for your
skin
so sunscreen um supergoop has unseen
sunscreen
and you cannot see it like it does not
leave a white residue
it's no it's really good for under your
makeup it's matte
it's it's very it's perfect i have that
that
from japan yeah someone recommended it
to me in a video a long time ago and i
use that
it's really good that's what i use okay
therapy
holy balls yes splurge on them and good
therapy because i did actually try to
see a therapist
in my early 20s when i really needed it
the most but i couldn't
afford that much so i went through my
insurance and it
he i think he did more damage to me
yeah than if i didn't go well he
basically so like
i had gone there because i felt like i
feel like i was going crazy
because we talked in a previous episode
about gaslighting and i was being
ghastly a lot and
i didn't know that term yet so i i just
said lying like
my boyfriend keeps lying to me and
saying i'm doing things i'm not doing
and like he's lying
and the therapist was like well
everybody lies you lie
you probably lie and i'm like that's
what he says to me like
and so
i really thought i was actually crazy
and it did
quite a bit of damage but anyway i so i
would have
invested in like a good therapist
if i if i had to splurge on something
right
yeah also like good um i mean it has
nothing to do with therapy but just
something i thought of that i wish i
would have spent
more money on in my early 20s was
quality pieces of
like staple pieces of clothing that will
actually like
last and or like jackets like legit
jackets or actual nice
sturdy shoes because i am so cheap when
it comes to spending anything on
on my wardrobe like i don't want to
spend more than like
25 on a shirt or something like i'm just
really really really
conservative with that but i actually
realized
especially in my 20s like i spent way
more money on
replacing clothes yeah because i
constantly have to keep replacing them
than if i would have just invested in
quality stuff like still to this day i
wanted
i still want to do that because i still
haven't done it but yeah like even just
looking into
what to invest in like that's something
i want to educate myself more
on but that's something i wish i would
have done even sooner because then i
could have just already been
having my wardrobe on yeah you actually
i feel like have the opposite
problem that most people are 27 where
they're spending way too much on clothes
but having those staple pieces i think
is really the key
is like yeah splurge on jeans like a
good pair of jeans
splurge on like a nice jacket stuff that
you can go to a job interview with
or a nice date like one nice dress
yeah you know i think i know how i
linked it to the therapy stuff because
when i when i was like in like latest
20s
that was the first time i actually spent
money on my wardrobe
and like i i bought like a whole bunch
of stuff i went to zara and i bought
so many things and once i started
wearing those outfits from
that that uh that buy like that chopping
spray thing that i did
i started feeling so much better about
myself just mentally because i had
always felt like
oh this is not money i need to spend on
myself like i need to worry about other
more important stuff which is true i
definitely needed to do that
but once i took the time and and effort
to actually
look into my own and like investing in
myself and making myself feel better
yeah like that made a big difference
like before you were kind of almost
subconsciously telling yourself you're
not important enough to spend this much
money
yeah that's that's a great breakthrough
true
mattress yes that's definitely on my
list mattress i used to have such a [ __ ]
mattress and i really think it really
messed up my back like
yes in the long run too and a pillow a
good pillow
yeah because i mean like that's where
your body needs it the most
so good mattress for sure also your
sleep is so important um and
in an undisturbed sleep cycle where
you're
because your body is basically like a
computer and if it doesn't get a decent
night's rest it's like
it's like you never turn off your
computer and it's just slowly degrading
and
pretty soon it freezes and you don't
know why what's wrong with your body
because you just never gave it the rest
it needed it needs to like
shut down all your systems like your
digestive system and
it just resets everything but if you're
getting interrupted all the time by your
poor
sleep or like the spring that keeps
jabbing into your back
or whatever futon you're sleeping on
yeah
yeah then you're you're not actually
allowing your body to get rest
i actually have a problem right now
because i have a lot of cats
and they all sleep with you well
two of them do and one is a kitten that
um
continuously he doesn't understand why
cats go to sleep at night like he's
sleeping all through the day and then
he's awake all through the night
and so he is jumping like between the
cracks and like trying to like play with
everybody while we're sleeping so
yeah um i have a really great mattress
didn't didn't i didn't realize that the
cat could throw that off but um
get yourself a really quality cat you
know
invest in that yeah yeah the ones that
sleep you know the older ones
um they say that uh a short amount of
good sleep
is better than a long amount of
constantly disturbed disrupted sleep
which is really true
that's so true the run cycle yeah
yeah i also have um on here
education you were talking about like
how you want to invest but you don't
know who to invest in
even just taking like a workshop or even
just uh books like
um different books on a subject you want
to learn
if you're just constantly upgrading your
skills or
learning new things learning new trades
learning whatever
whether you're taking like a class or
you're taking a weekend workshop or
you're just
reading a book like you're sharpening
something that's going to
bring value to your life so it is an
investment in yourself to put it into
education
that's so true because like yeah more
recently is when i started
reading books but i wish this was
something that i created a habit out of
myself like even in school because i
[ __ ] hated reading in school
it was like the worst assignment you
could possibly give me is to read a book
like i
[ __ ] hated reading and then
especially my 20s like i was too busy
with work and raising my kid to even
worry about that but
now in my 30s like now i actually have
free time and i'm like you know what
what is all this reading stuff about and
i'm learning so many cool things i'm
like
[ __ ] right i should have been doing this
a long time ago i didn't know i liked
reading either because
um i realized i i really only like
reading nonfiction books
and i hated books in school because they
were
like the reading list is you know novels
which is great it's nice to know stories
and like they all have themes and it's
good to get theory and all that stuff
but like i didn't feel like i didn't
know you could learn from books yeah
i thought they were just for stories me
too
[Laughter]
you can learn from books gina
yeah got it loud and clear
dude i even got a kindle that's how much
i love reading now yeah we love reading
yeah
yeah they're educated
[Laughter]
um yeah so education and then this is
one
that was listed in the instagram poll
like a lot of people
that are now in their 30s looking back
wish they would have splurged on travel
oh and that's what i was going to say i
think you should see the world like i
think that's totally something
worth spending money on but i also think
you can travel on a budget
and i didn't know that in my 20s i
thought you had to spend like tons of
money
if you wanted to travel at all um you
know what else you don't have to spend a
lot of money on
your clothes your clothes right oh
me yeah i don't have to spend a lot of
money there she is that first person
there she is
great that was a call back to early i
don't know if that's included
um okay so stitch fix if you
wish that you uh could have a new
wardrobe like tiff did um but you don't
want to spend a lot of money and you
don't
you want a stylus to pick up clothes for
you but you also don't want to spend
money on that
stitchbooks is great for you because
it's a subscription that you
can actually pause or start at any time
you don't have to have it on a monthly
basis but you can if you want to
and what you do is you go online you
take a test they'll show you a bunch of
pictures you say which ones you like and
which
ones you don't like and from that a
stylist can gather what your personal
style is
and then they will send you a box
curated just for you
with all kinds of clothes accessories
what have yous
i think you could even pick out i think
i picked out like little basics like a
camisole top and
things like that too so they have a lot
of jewelry too yeah they have
tons of accessories jewelry all that
stuff um there's no
subscription required but you can have
one if you want you but you pay
20 for a styling fee for each box but
that gets credited towards the pieces
you keep
so it's basically free if you buy a
shirt you didn't pay a styling fee
and there are no hidden fees ever stitch
fix has styles and clothing to fit any
occasion for women men and kids and they
ship
all over the u.s and available in the uk
as well mate
get started today at stitchfix.com mood
and you'll get 25
off when you keep everything in your fix
that's stitchfix.com
mood for 25 off when you keep everything
in your fix stitchfix.com
mood now you don't want to get any poop
on your pants dude i never do especially
on your new clothes
no on their pants right listen well
ever since we went to japan everyone has
been obsessed with getting a good day we
all have bidets now and i feel like if
you don't have a bidet then
gross i don't hang out dude you have a
mud butt
and if you guys don't want mud butt this
is where hello tissue comes in because
hello tissue will spray your butthole
with water
and we love that we like things all in
and around our buttholes love water
they like to be clean the new hello
tissue 3.0 has a new feature where it
cleans itself before and
after you use it it has a smart spray
it's called the smart spray which
automatically cleans itself
it attaches to your existing toilet it
requires no electricity or additional
plumbing so even an idiot like me can
attach it that's what i love about this
actually because i thought you had to
have an
um an outlet next to your toilet in
order to have a bad day and i was
getting very sad because you don't have
one and yeah and then
this and i'm like oh you don't even need
it it hooks up to the thing that's
already on your toilet
and it also cuts toilet paper use by
eighty percent
and you know during this whole
quarantine thing in their paper oh yeah
people were crazy
yeah because uh i don't know about you
but ever since i got a bidet
every poop wipe is a one white poop just
one
because your butt buckets cleaned
already you just gotta dry it
so the hellotishy bidet pays for itself
in just a few months now that it saves
you eighty percent of paper use
plus every hello tissue bidet attachment
comes with a 60-day risk-free guarantee
and a 12-month warranty
wow i just judge people who don't have
bidets now yeah i get it
you know yeah i mean especially since
it's so affordable it is exactly this is
like
70 like compared to like the hundreds
and hundreds of dollars that bidets
normally cost
for the rump you love to hump this
valentine's day give the gift of hello
tishi
because you want your significant
other's rump to be clean when you hump
it
right that's right go to hellotissue.com
big mood to get 10 off plus free
shipping
this is a special offer for our
listeners go to hellotissue.com
big mood for 10 off once again that's
hellotishie.com
big mood for 10 off for the rump that
you love to hump
it's like the vitamin benjamin
well gina's like yeah and she's gonna
live in a high rise apartment
for the rump you like to hump
we love you gina that was great that was
a great
life also i love that bidet it's just
pretty hilarious they're actually
they've got a great sense of humor i
wear the shirt they sent all the time
and everybody loves it the shirt that
says ask me about my bow yeah
i love their company it looks like a fun
place to work like their marketing
marketing team is great yeah exactly
okay
so um oh talking about travel
yeah i i um so the first time i ever
made like good money was when i was like
26 and that's when i remember when i was
gone forever yeah and i was in japan
like six times a year
that's because i was like dude [ __ ] it
i'm blowing it all and i'm well i didn't
plan on blowing at all
but i spent a lot of money traveling and
i splurged i'm like you know i'm in
another country i'm gonna get myself a
nice hotel room and do this and that
and i don't regret it at all
like in fact i wish i spent even more
money for more countries and stuff
yeah um because i remember the first
time i left a country i went to taiwan
for a month and it kind of like
opened up my eyes when i went from the
airport to the city because
you go from the airport and you drive
through like the very
very rural areas of taiwan and like it's
it's really sad and then you go to like
the glitz and glamorous city where like
19 year olds are driving
bentleys and i'm just like holy [ __ ]
like this really hit me to my core and
like
i remember messaging my boyfriend at the
time like i don't know why but i'm
really depressed because like i see
like shacks boarded up like shacks where
people live and then
like these [ __ ] you know the class
structures
yeah and that kind of like really hit
home and like really hit me hard and
made me feel some type of way about it
and i remember
my ex saying i'm really glad you're
feeling that because
you know when when you travel your mind
opens up a lot more and i'm really glad
that you're feeling that
yeah the cultural the cultural
experiences
are something that you just can't learn
in a book
you can't learn that you can read all
those books you can't get the same
experience
and that's why i'm so like so so
grateful that i've been able to do that
too and also bring isaac along to so
many of these trips
because him growing up and getting to
see all these different
walks of life like i i'm hoping that
when he gets older he can appreciate it
and i'm pretty sure like even if he
realizes or not
he's definitely absorbed a lot right
like yeah
it really opened my eyes a bit too
because i didn't get to
leave the us until i think i was like
27 um and even then
the first places that we went were just
europe so it was very like
everything's kind of the same same like
city i mean not not that europe's all
the same
it has a very rich history but the like
the class
structure like is pretty similar um like
london looks exactly like
new york um but then later we
um it wasn't until like 30's that i like
traveled to like bali and vietnam
and like you see like a completely
different culture
and i i just um i just
before i used to see travel as being
like you're going to the beach or you're
going to the city
i didn't see it as like each place has
such a different unique feeling to it
that's true until um i went to these
places and with each feeling it like
almost like deepens your life like
it deepens a part of you that you can
never go back to
the surface level that you were at
before that's true very enriching it's
good for your soul it's good for your
heart
um [ __ ] for some people it might even
make you less racist
i feel like true you know because a lot
of people like in
middle america have never seen any other
race have never
um experienced any other culture you
know
and and i i uh
this is kind of like a strange example
but i remember i went to um
taiwan for a month and i was with a girl
who never really traveled
and we took her to a gorgeous buddhist
temple
like it was like during a festival
ceremony whatever
and she was very like she
she was kind of like crazy i remember it
was like catholic or christian or not
and she was just like oh this is just so
disgusting like i just don't feel
comfortable here and i'm like dude get
the [ __ ] out are you about
more like this like this is rude you're
in someone else's house yeah you know
yeah respect their culture i'm not
telling you to worship their dangers and
their gods and stuff
but have some respect as they would for
you you know
so i feel like it in some cases it might
make someone a more
uh open-minded accepting person and it
educates them more
and makes them want to learn more about
other cultures yeah usually when people
are uh racist or sexist or whatever it's
they're
they're homophobic they're coming from a
place of fear something they don't
understand
and so yeah traveling and seeing
different cultures
when it's there and they're in it
hopefully
they can get a better understanding of
what
uh how different people live and then
it's not something to be feared anymore
yeah or the [ __ ] they hear in their
circle just
yeah exactly no one really knows like
they want to get to experience something
different
that's true so i wish i spent more even
more money
on that on traveling yeah yeah when you
travel like not being like cheap and
like okay well we can only like stay at
the hotel
right you know like definitely splurging
on life experiences is
always worth it yeah absolutely i think
for sure
but be safe don't be dumb yeah don't
rack up
like credit card debt that you that
might [ __ ] you up or like go to certain
places that are
dangerous yeah exactly alone yeah yeah i
mean like those group tours are
a good like there's even this uh one
group tour that specializes
like their their whole company is only
for twenties
like people in their twenties yeah
there's so much boning going on
i used to serve them um because they the
australian one would come and visit
santa barbara and i worked at a
restaurant then they would it would get
flooded with australians
and then uh i was like a banquet server
so
we had like oh contiki night is this
night yeah
but yeah so like there's so many options
for young
people on a budget to still travel and
see the world and be safe
yeah yeah and then okay so moving on to
like
things that you would save on the top
things that came in from instagram
were uh cars nice cars don't [ __ ] do
it don't buy a
new car or lease like a new car
you just okay i get the thrill because
you
it's cool right but then it wears off in
like a day or two or like a week
maybe like and then you realize no one
gives a [ __ ]
like no one cares now you're stuck with
this big payment
and unless i mean if you can if you're
loaded and you're also really passionate
about cars that makes sense
but if you're just getting one because
you're like oh i'm making a bit more
money so let me increase my spending
don't do that don't the biggest mistake
people make is like when they make a
little bit more money they immediately
maximize
max out their spending and it's just not
worth it because that money could be
growing
yep i just i see so many like in their
20s
like dude you you just have like a
regular day job
at [ __ ] forever 21. why are you
driving a bmw
yeah what the [ __ ] are you doing i'm 31
years old
i can afford a nice car i still stick to
my like my
honda civic well honda civic's actually
something that i would say
spend your money on that yeah because
those cars last a long time a car i
bought in my 20s
yeah i drive a honda civic honda club
yeah exactly
and like can i get a nicer car yes but
cars
depreciate in value immediately if you
buy a new car it depreciates
five thousand dollars as soon as you
drive it off the lot yeah five thousand
dollars immediately just like that just
for driving off a lot you can't bring it
back if you brought it back they
it's five thousand dollars less right
and it like and honestly when it boils
down to it when it really really really
really boils down to it unless you're
like
unless you're like super into cars then
i get it but when it really boils down
to it
you're really doing it just to try to
impress other people yeah that's [ __ ]
sad stop it
people that you probably don't even like
yeah truly your 20s you're all
you're all about trying to fit in yeah
trying to impress others
exactly no one's ever been like gina
what the [ __ ] where are you driving
civic like no one gives a [ __ ]
no spend money on having a quality good
car that can drive you from a to b
and not break down but after that like
no not like
you don't need something flashy you
really just don't i i know like
attorneys that still drive [ __ ] box cars
you know because it's like people who
make
money understand like this is a waste of
millionaires
and out of control most millionaires i
know are really good at
saving money like they're really good at
not increasing their debt on stupid
things
true it's only like i think it just it
also
it's around your own values too like
what brings value to your own life yeah
because like for example when i was in
my 20s and like i had
a really shitty run-down car that i
bought for like 1200
and that was like my first car and uh i
like i had it for a short amount of time
and then i crashed it
and then that's when i went
but it kind of was a little bit but it
wasn't
but um but yeah so then it was totaled
like i couldn't fix that car
and so i ended up buying a car a brand
new car and i went to the dealership and
i got this honda civic
and it was a 2010 honda civic and i was
just like yay
brand new car but i didn't negotiate for
[ __ ]
at all and i totally wish i would have
educated myself a little bit i even took
my friend
and her mom because they swore that they
were great at negotiating women say
anything yeah once again that's damaging
i'm gonna get canceled so hard sorry god
but for real like they didn't say [ __ ]
and so like um and then i didn't know
anything either so
whatever i ended up uh buying like a
really
expensive honda civic and
and yeah and so like that i had that car
for
almost nine years and it lasted me a
really long time it was great and then
the next car i got which is the car i
currently have is a tesla and
yeah it's really expensive it's it's um
it's a debt i don't necessarily need to
have but it adds so much value to
to my personal life where like i now am
happy to be in a car and get to from
point a to point b when in the past i
dreaded it like it was obviously it was
the worst like i always had like i was
always so grumpy
in my car because it was always giving
me issues like it was a good car but
like it wouldn't accelerate
when i needed to or whatever and like i
there were just little things that
drove me crazy and so not until i
upgraded
my driving experience and now i feel
calmer and i feel like it added a lot of
value to my personal life so it really
not saying that you should go out and
buy a tesla but it's
i think it it's where your values lie
right
yeah so that goes into like that reminds
me of when
i was living at home with my family yeah
rent was 400 a month
but i was miserable yeah like i was
[ __ ]
miserable not because of anything they
did but like the place barely got any
sunlight
like it was just like kind of old or
whatever you know and i'm just this
sucks but i'm saving money
yeah so it really like it it depends on
what
you deem most valuable in your life and
if that helps you that comes with
knowing yourself
yeah right i i've learned through and i
didn't know why before but um
now i know for a fact i'm such a big
environment person
i need my environment to be bright and
light inspiring
airy um aesthetically pleasing
but i don't have to spend a lot of money
on it i just needed it to be
nicer and i needed it to be my own space
so yeah
living with my parents was not fun
because i felt like i couldn't really
make the decisions
and i kind of creatively need to be in
control of like what the space looks
like
um and when we first moved from our
two-bedroom apartment which had a lot of
space it was a really good deal and it
was a really good part of town like the
location was like
impeccable it was one of the like
highest rated neighborhoods in
l.a um to walk in it was where the brady
bunch house was
um and so it was a really good area but
it was dark as [ __ ]
like you could not keep plants in there
you could not keep flowers in there like
it and the carpet was disgusting it like
had
hadn't been replaced in years um and
so it just like we were saving money
we were in a nice location i thought it
was a good deal it was a lot of space
for the value
but i just wasn't inspired and i found
myself really depressed and then not
creatively
uh able to do like we were gonna create
a field and so
creatively i need to be there and i just
felt myself just like kind of dying
inside
and even though our place now cost like
a bit more a month um so much better and
i've gotten
way more jobs and stuff just because i'm
so
much more creatively fulfilled because
of the environment so yeah don't uh
that's one thing um save your money but
don't be frugal
at the expense of your mental health
yeah that's the main thing that i was
trying to get out with this whole car
thing that's exactly yeah
that's what it is um when jess is here
and i think that's why i was like unless
you're passionate about cars and like
that's your thing and it's not taking a
huge chunk of your
uh income yeah it's not responsible yeah
exactly because jess is very into luxury
cars
and that's she has a bmw and for her
like that's worth it
for me i'm like i can't tell the
difference between a bmw or a honda when
i'm driving it
i'm just like that's a car yeah like i
like cars but i'm also
a very like point a to point b person
yeah ac
heater it's nice and you know it's music
and everything it's fun like my gp
or my phone can hook up to it i'm fine
yeah whereas like
house stuff i'm like i just gush over
but even there i'm like a couple staple
items like
having good quality staple items that
are aesthetically pleasing and
you don't have to replace that often
yeah and then you can replace the
decor around it either through diys or
like thrift stores or
estate cells or cheap you know you can
you can be frugal there
and still change up the look and have it
look nice
um so this is actually a very
interesting
thing i wanted to bring up i'm a firm
believer in
time is money and uh i believe that
money can be made if you lose money you
can always make it back again but you
can never make back time yes so
my thing is if i can
pay someone to do something that i hate
for me
just so i can have my time to do
something i actually enjoy
i will 100 do that totally yeah i did
not get that
until recently like probably when i hit
my 30s um
but a house cleaner yeah yeah exactly
i used to think that was just for rich
people but they're really not
that expensive and they if you have one
come in
like once every two weeks even to just
do the cleaning part like
i can kind of keep things tidy on my own
but i am so bad at cleaning
i don't know how to do it i feel like i
spent hours doing it and it still
doesn't look all the way clean
why not have a professional come in they
do it in an hour and
they're really good at their jobs it's a
really really
like that expense totally brings you so
much time and also
like relaxation mental space
exactly you don't have to stress out
about that i have ours come every three
weeks
same oh nice so and then like yeah like
you could space it out too
and if you're able to like at least
maintain like the upkeep a little bit
in between time then you can save money
by like spreading them out too you know
what helped me save money
a pandemic i haven't been able to have a
house cleaner in my house for so long
and no one noticed because
that's how i feel too because you know
what else you should take care of though
first is your hair
gina yeah that's right how's your hair
doing splurge on your hair
yep um my hair is doing pretty great i
don't know if you can if you're watching
on youtube maybe you can check out the
shine i just watched it this morning
this pandemic got me washing my hair
like once every week and a half or
something
save money there too actually the
function of beauty who's our sponsor
right now um
they oh my god they do a phenomenal job
i love them so much
but i it's taken me like eight months to
get through this shampoo and conditioner
because
one i don't wash my hair that often and
two it's just so such good quality
that i don't need to and people don't
notice i just ordered another set
it's so good like we got like last year
yeah okay so what you're gonna do is
just like stitch fix you're gonna go
online and they're gonna ask you a bunch
of questions about your hair like what
are your hair goals
do you want less frizz do you want it to
be more straight do you want more volume
what do you want your hair to be like
what is your ideal hair
style and then they have over i think
like
400 different combinations maybe more
that they can do uh with their
ingredients to create a 100
custom solution for you and uh and they
also
do it with conditioner and then you can
even pick the scent and the color
or you can ask for no scent um if that
kind of
irritates you or whatever um and then
you also get a custom bottle so it has
your name on it
it says function of limo on mine
i just like it saying my last name
because it sounds more regal
the function of nikki i really want to
push a limit and see if they're willing
to
print anything that i'd say function
what would you have a function of
dumbbitch
they probably would that'd be great
because how could they prove that's not
your
name i call you dumb [ __ ] all the time
exactly maybe i
identify as a dumbass yes exactly
i think they respect that you should do
it yeah i should
have done it and function of beauty now
offers a new skincare line it's the same
quality and customization you expect
but now for your skincare routine i love
those lotions
yeah i got the eucalyptus in it so every
time i put my lotion on it's like minty
it's like a spa um
yeah never buy off the shelf just to be
disappointed ever
again okay go to functionofbeauty.com
big mood
to take your quiz and save 20 on your
first order that applies to their full
range of customized hair skin
and body products go to
functionalbeauty.com big mood to let
them know we sent you and to get twenty
percent off your order
function of beauty.com big mood you know
what guys
times are tough and worrying about your
student loan payments
does doesn't make things any easier
especially because of this damn pandemic
we're in so that's where refinancing
with earnest could help
so earnest offers low rate student loan
refinancing
and you can check and you can check your
rate risk-free in just
two minutes with earnest you get
radically flexible payments and you can
pick your loan term
by refinancing you can reduce your loan
terms save money or combine multiple
loans
into one simple monthly payment and if
you have questions you can even talk to
a real
life human at earnest for help isn't it
time you stopped feeling overwhelmed by
your student
debt ernest is offering our listeners a
100
cash bonus refinance your student debt
at earnest.com big mood
terms and conditions apply that's right
ernest is giving our listeners
a 100 bonus refinance your student loans
at earnest.com
big mood turns and condition terms and
conditions imply
once again you get a 100 dollar
cash bonus 200 dollars that's a lot of
dollars
for that when you visit earnest.com
big mood to refinance your student loan
not available in all states
terms and conditions apply visit
earnest.com big mood for more details
terms and conditions apply student loan
refinancing made by earnest operations
llc and mls number one two zero four
nine one seven california financing law
license number six zero five four seven
eight eight three oh three second street
suite 401 north san francisco california
nine four one zero seven visit
earnest.com
licenses for a full list of licenses the
house cleaner thing is not only just
like good for your house but i went
through like a
a really bad depressive yeah where i had
a depression den
couldn't walk through my room i couldn't
leave my bed and everything was just so
messy and i was just like i don't want
to deal with this
so my housekeepers i love them so much
it's a team of three women
um i you know they they came by one week
and when i opened my front door i was
like
listen i've been like really depressed
and can you guys just focus on my room i
just need a fresh start
and it was so worth the money like they
clean everything they gave me a hug
they're like
you're going to do this there's three
sweet mexican ladies they're obsessed
with my cat i told him his name was
ignacio's middle name they call him
nacho
nacho from nacho library so whenever
they see him they're like oh nachita
like it's the [ __ ] thing and then
like and like they hug me afterwards
like we love you and then it's like it's
it's good for your mental health
so you're not like just clutter in the
room clutters your mind to
it really does and so like having a
house cleaner or
or anything that helps you save time so
you can use that time for something more
productive or something that you are
passionate about or happy about
completely worth the money
yeah exactly unless you're a person that
loves to clean yeah unless
that's what brings you joy the great
someone spend your money somebody told
me i was like oh so you're like
31 and you have to have someone clean
for you like why don't you just work
hard and do it yourself i'm like
i work hard so i can afford
are you kidding me you can't work hard
on everything you're going to spread
yourself so
thin yeah yeah yeah that's not working
efficiently
and also i'm just i just know i'm not
good at it
like and as much as i can work on that
skill i'm just not going to be as good
as a house cleaner
and the time it takes is not worth the
investment exactly
yeah 100 um okay so some people might be
thinking like
how do you have any extra income to buy
any of these things and that is
something i wish i would have done more
in my 20s and i do it
i started pretty pretty young like maybe
like um mid-20s doing this but
every quarter i do do a budget for our
house and i budget out
all of our expenditures on paper i know
where every dollar needs to go
and then i know how much is left over
and what i used to do
before when i felt like i had no extra
spending money and i was like how am i
ever going to save or do anything
i would pay myself 10 of my income and
then have to figure out how to
pay everything else because i firmly
believe this you should pay yourself
first
you should your the government gets your
money the bill pay
the bill people get your money the your
landlord gets your money
but you never get your money even you're
the one working that's how a lot of
people operate
put that 10 away no matter what and for
me at least it motivated me
to find more ways to make income like to
up my income stream whether that's
asking for a raise or
finding a side hustle that brings in an
extra income
whatever that was at least i now had
this padding because
you need some sort of padding you can't
be relying on
nothing going wrong you need that for an
emergency
so putting that 10 away if you have debt
that 10 first goes to an emergency fund
that's like 500
and then start putting that 10 towards
paying off all your debt
once all your debt is paid off now that
10 goes into building your emergency
fund bigger
once you have about three months of
savings saved up then you can start
using that 10
to do these extra spending things but
that's the order that i would go in
um and that's how i tackled that problem
because i really got depressed thinking
like i'm never gonna
make any extra money there's no such
thing as disposable income like
it's always gonna be paycheck to
paycheck but you have to force it you
just have to
find out where you can save or if you
don't want to save on certain things
like you're just not willing to like
skimp the quality on things then find
out how you can make more money
right learn how to cook that's actually
one of the ones i was gonna say too
because there's always ways where you
can figure out
within your budget where you can put
money away that you don't have to spend
right that you can save and cooking is
one of them
um that's something that i wish in my
20s i would have done more
i mean i did cook but
not as much as i probably should have um
and also
it's just the skills it's like a good
life skill that i totally just don't
even have anymore because
my husband comes cooks yeah luckily you
made someone that can cook
i know i'm like so lucky but um but yeah
and then you can also save so much more
money too and just buying groceries
versus like
post mates and drive-throughs and it's
also better for your health
but another thing that i was thinking of
that i did in my 20s that i
so regret and i know it's not just the
20s thing like
people get sucked into this if you're
just not very bright
is like scams kind of stuff so
and or younger people are more easily
susceptible to fall for these scams and
elderly
and elderly elderly for sure scam the
earlier i hope you find i know
i know just die so i bought a
a travel club points thing let's just
call it a
time share even though it's not
technically a time share but
yeah casey and i like we we got into
this thing because i was just so
i wanted to travel so bad and this whole
thing here is like where you buy a
certain amount of
points that you can put into depending
on where you want to go
and it's just such a [ __ ] scam like
don't fall for it are you stuck in it um
so there have been
there have been resources out there that
i should have looked into but i didn't
so i'm technically still still in it i
paid it off so it's like a
a certain amount of money it's like it's
kind of like buying a car like once you
pay for it like it's yours but every
year there's like a
membership fee so i'm still paying that
membership fee every year
and not once have i ever used it not
once because the amount of points that i
bought it's like not even enough to
make it a full vacation like it's just
it's [ __ ] it's just
so dumb and i think i was so young and
like so
excited and eager to travel
and i thought this was such a good deal
and i didn't really
read the fine print i didn't realize how
the sales people were just so
um what's the word like praying on us
yeah um
and yeah like i i didn't take into
consideration
any of that stuff see this is where i
get upset with people calling people
dumb for that because
it's really um it's really a social
class thing because i
i did the same thing and it's it's not
really fair because if you didn't grow
up if you like have goals of traveling
let's say in your case and you didn't
have people in your family that could
afford to go traveling all the time
so they didn't tell you how it's
supposed to be done and you're kind of
trying to figure out for yourself like
how you can make it possible
of course you're gonna like be like you
don't know what information is correct
and what's not
and what's out there you don't nothing
about it and you don't have anyone to
talk to
so yeah you're gonna fall for scams and
if it sounds like
a good deal if it sounds too good to be
true it probably is but
um i think that that's just a learning
experience because then as you actually
eventually figure it out because you are
dedicated to like figuring it out right
you're like oh [ __ ]
i shouldn't have done that yeah looking
back but now you can warn other people
out there
yeah i did the same thing when i was
getting into acting
because i wanted to pursue acting but
that's not really a career that's
that at least back then wasn't really
encouraged for
um you to go out and be an actor because
it's like secure
yeah it wasn't secure and it's just like
a pipe dream and like whatever but i'm
like no
you know people do this and people take
it seriously it is a profession
um so i knew i could do it i just didn't
know exactly how
and i did fall for one of those scams
that was like because i knew in reading
all the books i read all the books about
it like okay here's all the steps here's
how you do it step by step
and the next step on the page for me was
um to get an agent and to get like
management
i had no idea how to do it no like it's
much easier now with the internet but
back then
it was very tough and so i googled
and whatever came up was um one of those
like
fly to florida and you meet like 20
agents and you're in this like show
and like um they had ashton kutcher on
there i was like look he came out of
this
showcase or whatever so i was like oh
[ __ ] ashton kutcher came out of that
showcase
oh i signed me up and at the time it was
so expensive for me it was like
i think it was like a thousand dollars a
month because i couldn't pay
all up front but it ended up being
something like
something like five thousand dollars and
then the ceo fled because he was like
tax evading wow
and all that yeah he went bankrupt he
and all of that money
just disappeared no way yeah they paid
it did you go
i couldn't no there was no it was before
that wow
yeah or there was never a florida thing
there was because they had held it like
in the past it was way overpriced um and
you had to pay for your own flight and
hotel even on top of the
workshop fee but in my head i was like
well this is what you have to do to like
if i don't have an in to get
representation then i just have to like
make an investment in myself you know
and looking back it's like oh
i know how to get there now but i didn't
know back then
and that was just a learning experience
and it sucks i definitely got prayed on
definitely got taken advantage of but i
wouldn't call it stupid because there
was just nobody i had no mentor i had
nobody in the industry i could talk
about
that
stupid but but so many people who look
at me and be like look at you you try to
go after your dreams and you got scammed
same with traveling like look you tried
to see the world and you got scammed
actually even like the therapy stuff too
like there's a lot of
cults that prey on people looking for
help and people get sucked into these
cult culty things so you gotta be
careful about that too read reviews
like do your homework oh yeah just be
careful do your research
and learn from other people's mistakes
oh yeah i remember i went to like one of
those my friends like oh yeah it's like
some meeting for some business thing or
whatever
i'm like all right yeah i'll come with
you and i'll go check it out
a multi-level marketing yeah and i i
smelled [ __ ] because like
during that meeting they planted someone
in the audience oh
[ __ ] and like every time the speaker
said something this guy was just like
whoa yeah i'm like man you would not
make it in the acting world you suck at
this
i called him out immediately like i was
in my head i was like all right this is
[ __ ] you know
and then um and then uh and then another
friend of mine who was like
yeah there's this thing called landmark
and it teaches you blah blah blah
you know like and then i hated it
because like landmark's like a life
coaching
[ __ ] or whatever he's like yeah you
should take one of classes i was like 17
and then i was like okay well how much
is the class you're like it's 500 i'm
like [ __ ] you
i'm 17. it's the same thing as religion
where
like okay it might work for some people
yeah maybe some people are very helped
by it and they like
the feeling of a sense of community and
structure and being part of something
bigger than themselves
plus they're learning things that they
never learned before and and it's great
and but then it's when they like really
need to push it on
other people that it's like okay you do
you
yeah do what makes you happy but when
you have to push it on other people
that's all you talk about and that's all
you're told to talk about that's when it
becomes a cult
yeah difficult like all the the uh the
pyramid scheme stuff
on yeah like every year i see like a
couple people like oh i'm selling blah
blah blah
like message me on howard like they'll
hit you up like hey girl it hasn't been
there it's been so long
[ __ ] talk to me don't you talk to me
i got yeah i got that out of my system
early
my mom was in amway so i knew about
pyramid schemes from the beginning well
not pyramid schemes but mlm
yeah i don't want to call everything a
pyramid scheme because pyramid schemes
are actually illegal this is part of
their talking points to when they when
you
ever have someone go take you to an mlm
meeting it's like did you know that
pyramid schemes are actually illegal so
how could this be appearance
okay so it's not a pyramid scheme but uh
yeah multi-level marketing
um she's she was in amway so i already
knew about that life
and then when i uh i went to one of
those things it was actually i was
tricked into going to one
because he asked me out on a date oh no
and i was so desperate for love
he was 18. um yeah and then
immediately like we went to someone's
he's like hey can we stop by my friend's
like business
uh launch business launch
um yeah he's launching a new business
and i'm like okay i'm thinking it's like
a restaurant
or something like cool business thing
yeah
we end up going to some guy's living
room and they play a dvd
and then they um then there's a guy
that's not his friend
that's talking about what we just
watched on the dvd
and i was like this is amway they're
like no it's not amway
but this is like it's like amway because
my mom was
like no well okay it's similar to amway
but it's not
amway at all and then um i ended up
joining
okay all right vicky i thought there was
going to be a saving grace here
i thought well that's the initial
investment was too good to pass up oh
my god they offered me such a deal okay
but i ended up making um a good amount
of money from the direct sales portion
of it and then i
um quit like i just did it to pay off to
pay off my car and then i
then i quit but i also thought it was so
fascinating
i stayed to observe everyone and i got
so much good material
because there are all kinds of walks of
life in that and i really dedicated
myself like i went to all i went to the
national conventions
the ones that are in oklahoma city like
i
i flew i went to them because i wanted
to see
i wanted to know i wanted to know what
happened there
and i feel like i could write a whole
show of it now so wow you know
experiences are interesting
but um would i would i become
part of a cult no i could ex i could see
how people do though right yeah they
prey on the young
the the needy and and when you hear
people talk at these things it's always
like
our house was going into foreclosure we
had no other
way to make money and it's like oh my
gosh this is sad like
yeah they prey on people that are in
really desperate situations
and then they appeal to you emotionally
so that like it's like
yeah i get that i was there too i'm just
like you
yeah look at me now i look like i own
this my mom was also involved in a lot
of those
yeah and so she would actually take me
to some of these like
meetings or whatever they call them and
um i remember she was one
and one called like pre-america
primarily america yeah yeah she was in
that and i remember her saying in one of
these
get-togethers that she ended up saying
like this is too good to be true
and then the guy was like you think this
is too good to be true
well i'm here to tell you that you're
wrong this is
just good it's not good too good to be
true
it was just so corny that i'm like i was
looking at my mom like
are you falling for this yeah but she
was in it for
some time and i was just like what the
hell you know what's funny is there
that pur that mlm is what got me into
reading books though
and then i ended up loving reading books
all the books they recommended were so
good and then they wanted you to use
those books to do well in the company
like
you know go after your dreams and like
you can manifest anything you want and
like the secret all that [ __ ]
and i i was like well but i've always
wanted to be an actor
and then i used that to just go to
pursue acting
um so yeah it was very it was an
interesting experience
yeah and i don't recommend joining one
but
interesting for sure i remember um the
the
the one that tried to get me to join
landmark yeah we were dating and like
it's a life coach thing so like they
teach you how to
navigate through life with like this and
that whatever and the thing that i hated
most about it
was whenever we got into an argument
instead of arguing normally you'd be
like
are you sure this is not just a defense
mechanism that you're and i'm like
like over and over again i'm like i will
[ __ ] kill you right now god like
like argue with me but in his head he's
like she doesn't get it yeah i have to
guide her
yeah yeah no in the in that thing i i
remember it was very like an insider
thing like oh they don't get like the
normie
you know like yeah they they don't know
that they can go after their dreams like
we have to tell them like that kind of
there was a lot of that going on in in
there very culturally yeah it was very
cold see and if you weren't succeeding
it was because you just like weren't
believing in yourself and
investing enough yeah right you weren't
doing enough
um exposures right yeah so anyway guys
that went into a cool tangent about
pyramid schemes but that's the subject
for another time i hope you got a lot
out of
this and what what we [ __ ] up on and
would have changed if we were to go back
into our 20s if you're in your 20s now
just
invest man invest in yourself invest in
your health invest in your skincare
invest in your sleep
but don't invest in your alcohol and
don't invest
in expensive cars yeah or like a lot of
clothes that will go out of
trend in a month or two and get
roommates
yeah yeah good roommates good ones in a
good in a nice environment in a nice
environment
don't sacrifice safety and mental health
just to save money yeah exactly
all right also make sure you give us
five stars i heard that that is
something you should splurge on
it's very it's free it's free so splurge
your free
fingers onto clicking five stars
and we love you and we will see you next
time bye